المقاومه الشعبيه بالنسبه لنا واضحه هي
هبه هبه وطنيه للدفاع عن الارض والعرض
والوطن وهي حق دستوري للناس في حال انه
واجهوا عدو هذا العدو يقصدهم يقصد يقتلهم
وداير ينهب وداير يسرق ارضه وداير يمثل بم
وممكن يرتكب اي مستوى من مستويات
الانتهاكات المقاومه الشعبيه ضروره اصلا
وواجب الان يجب انه كل السودانيين يتعلموا
من الدرس الذي حدث في في ولايه الجزيره
انه الاستعداد للحرب وحمل السلاح مع
القوات المسلحه وبضوابط وبامر والاستعداد
في اماكنهم وفي قراهم وفي بلداتهم وفي
مدنهم بيعني عدم تمدد الحرب يبقى المقاومه
الشعبيه المسلحه هي ضمان للسلام اول حاجه
وهي ضمان لانه ما تحصل انتهاكات لان هذه
المليشيا الجبانه هي مليشيا غادره في
الاساس مليشيا تقوم على الغدر وتقوم على
قتل العزل وتقوم على اغتصاب النساء
والاطفال ومهاجمه الضعاف من الناس
والضعفاء من الناس لكن متى ما استعد
الشباب يجب الاف السودانيين الان القادرين
على حمل السلاح ان يحملوا
سلاح